in this video we'll be talking about
dandy walker malformation which is a
congenital brain malformation
predominantly affecting the cerebellar
development
cerebellum is a region in the brain that
regulates balance coordination movement
posture Etc so obviously one can
understand what is the manifestation of
this disease dandy walker malformation
is a congenital malformation which leads
to a cystic dilation of the fourth
ventricle
so there is a portion back of the Hedge
head which bulge out
and there is a hypoplasia or agenesis of
the cerebellar varmis
then there is enlargement of the
posterior fossa and these are the
predominant or the key features of
dandywalker malformation
these kind of features of Daniel Walker
malformation can be detected using MRI
imaging
so this is how a control and the dandy
walker malformation look like notice the
cerebellum nicely pointed out in the
control MRI whereas if you look at the
MRI of a dandy walker patient the
cerebellum look pretty much small so
obviously there is an over overall
hypoplasia of the cerebellum
and moreover there is a cystic dilation
of the fourth ventricle there are too
much of cerebrospinal fluid which are
obstructed in these particular ventricle
that creates the Bulge in the back of
the head
so obviously in the during the birth
there is a appearance of macrocephaly
the macrocephalic appearance is mostly
due to the obstructive nature of the
overall fourth ventricle there are fluid
accumulation
so this is how exactly the sagittal
coronal and horizontal view of an MRI
look like for a dandy walker patient
this is how our skull fossa look like
this is the anterior cranial fossa
medial and posterior cranial fossa in
case of dandy walker malformation the
posterior Canal fossa is defective so
this is how a normal MRI which
which looks like this this is the
overall cerebellum
and here you can see the in the dandy
walker malformation the posterior fossa
is becoming much more thin
and this is how the cerebellum is
looking at
so the central part of the cerebellum is
kind of messed up
that means the vermis area is the one
which is most affected
and this is how the fluid accumulation
look like
anyway warm is area of the cerebellum is
pretty important for motor coordination
and it plays crucial role in balance and
posture as well
and histological findings of dandy
walker malformation shows that there is
an overall reduction in the
foliation of the cerebellum but the most
affected region is the flocculonodular
lobe and the overall number of lobules
are reduced in number
so this is how it looks like in the
normal and this is how it looks like in
the dandy walker malformation
so overall the inferior part of the worm
is is hype it's undergoing hypoplasia
so the diagnostic signatures of dandy
walker malformation involves a signature
known as the tail sign and this has been
recently proposed based on current
research so this is a 20 post coitus
weak embryo which has a denti-walker
malformation you can clearly see the
posterior part of the cerebellum appears
like a dog's tail and it's kind of like
curved so this is the tail sign for the
dandy walker malformation and it has
been seen that out of the patients which
are examined or interpreted with dandy
walker malformation 75 percent of the
patients show this kind of symptom and
this is the latest research that talks
about this
and this kind of tail sign appears due
to the reduced growth of the posterior
varmis and it correlates with the
failure of rhombic lip region to
internalize in a particular cerebral
development so rhombic lip is a germinal
Zone which has stem cells for different
cerebellar cell types
so rhombic lip marked here in the red
give rise to cell types like
granule cells which are glutamateragic
cells deep cerebellar nuclear cells or
dcns and also it give rise to unipolar
brush cells so quite a lot of different
cell types in the cerebellum appears
from this rhombic lip and it is
speculated that rhombic lip is the
origin of this particular disease and
the problems are happening at the level
of rhombic lip and the cells that comes
out of the rhombically
now dandy walker syndrome is pretty much
uh pleiotropic basically
symptom shows different type of
involvement of genes and pathways
also the phenotypic variability and
diversity is quite massive you can see
there are MRI from three patient and
three of these patients shows different
degree of severity
when it comes to genetics Trisomy 18
Trisomy 13 21 and 9 are associated with
Dandy Walker's malformation
also the RNA sequencing experiment from
the rhombic clip of dandy walker
malformation patient reveals an
interesting aspect there is a reduction
in proliferation and the stemness
related genes from the dandy walker
malformation patient that explains why
the rhombic lip is dysmorphic and
undergoes atrophy
now symptoms as mentioned before
includes delayed motor Milestones
hypotonia motor coordination defects or
Ataxia also there could be other
signatures like prominent occiput
craniofacial abnormalities like cleft
palate upward slanting of the eyes Etc
but these are variable and not present
in all the patients
treatment and management includes
incorporation of the VP shunt or Ventra
peritoneal shunt requires a surgery for
this kind of implantation this would
drain the excess fluid to the peritoneum
and that's how the intracranial pressure
would be balanced
other supportive treatment includes
physiotherapy speech therapy and
supportive medications so I hope this
video was useful if you like this video
give it a big thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe support our
Channel using super thanks see you in
next video